Well, welcome everyone. I hope you're having a good meeting so far.
Certainly, a beautiful day here in San Diego.
Early part of the meeting, and this is a really special session because
what's it all about but patient-centered clinical trials, bringing
science from the lab to the clinic, access, getting
patients access in rural areas. Something that's really on my mind these days.
So I'm really excited. I'm Roy Herbst.
I'm from the Yale Cancer Center in New Haven, Connecticut, and I'll be moving to
Dartmouth actually this summer. So,
really excited to be your moderator today.
I also chair the Scientific Policy and Government Affairs Committee, which
is where some of these policy and regulatory programs
developed.
Here are my disclosures.
Why is this important? Why are we here today?
Only 7% of US adult cancer patients enroll in clinical trials.
Shame on us. Is it because we don't have enough trials?
Is it because the trials aren't developed in a way that they're accessible to
patients? Do patients not trust us?
Do we not have physicians that
represent the community? Do we not have enough resources?
Probably all of the above, and you'll hear about that today.
80% of cancer care occurs outside major academic centers.
Probably even more, but remember, academic centers now are not what they used to
be. Where I work at Yale right now, we have 16 sites around Connecticut
and Rhode Island where we see patients.
Up at Dartmouth, they have multiple sites around their state.
So every center now is in the community.
Trials, unfortunately, are concentrated in urban tertiary institutions.
Parking is an issue. I grew up in New York.
People tell me they can't park in New Haven. I laugh a bit, but it's hard.
It takes money. It takes time. Caregivers need to travel with
patients. It is something we need to combat.
So the core disconnect.
Trials happen at academic centers. They're centralized.
There's a specialized infrastructure. There are so many fricking tests.
Look, has anyone here ever tried to schedule an MRI for themself?
Imagine if you have to get it within a week for a patient.
And where patients receive care, in the community, in rural settings, the
majority of patients are treated there, and there's limited trial access, or the
trials are so complicated, so burdensome that the staff, the
patient, just can't do it.
Consequences for the science and patients are slow trial accrual,
underrepresented real-world populations,
limited generalizability of results, and missed
opportunities for patient benefit.
So this panel
is just going to discuss ways that we can combat this.
So here are some emerging
solutions, pragmatic trials.
I can't help but mention we have a dignitary here, Dr. Rick Pazdur.
And Rick has been... Actually, I met him first at MD Anderson when he was running
the fellowship, and his wife, Mary, was a dear friend of mine and worked with me as
my nurse practitioner. But Rick actually coined this pragmatic
trials, with Ellen Siegel one night on a phone call. And Rick, we did one.
We need to do more, and I'm so happy you're at our session today.
And Rick's actually going to be working a bit for the AACR, so we look forward to
having even more interaction with you.
Then we'll hear about hybrid decentralized models.
Pat Lorusso is sitting here, and we're going to hear about maybe we could do the
best in both worlds. Some of the science and some of the hard stuff at the
main center, but get it out to the community where people are.
Then we're going to hear about community-engaged research, and we're going to hear
about that from our panel. We have some of the world-leading experts.
This is the panel, and this is going to be available for years to come on the
video, and this is not our first
action. There's much going on.
So how do we do this? Local screening with centralized trial coordination.
You'll hear that from Pat. Reduce visit burden through hybrid
participation. Constantin's going to tell you about Lung Pragmatica.
We have Electra here. You'll hear from Camille.
Use of existing community care infrastructure.
Use what we have, but maximize it. And simplified eligibility and
procedures.
The patient voice. That's what it's all about.
We must incorporate patient input into protocol design.
We have the Scientist Survivor Program. There are patients at this meeting.
450 patients. Where are the patients? Let's hear it for the patients.
Ah.
So we're already successful, Pat, because this is the session that attracted the
patients. This is what we want. But we don't have enough slots.
450 people from countries all over the world applied to be part of the program this
year. We only selected 50. Of course, many people could come on their own.
But thank you. Thank you. This is what we need. We need to listen to our patients.
Address logistical barriers, time, travel, cost.
Rick used to tell me we put so many...
I'm Jewish, but he tells me we have all these Christmas tree ornaments on our
trials. Take it off. But everyone's afraid to do that.
Why do you need to test every single lab value, take time, cost
money? Building trust through community partnerships and ensuring
relevance to real-world care, because that's what it's all about.
What good is that? There's a new G12D drug we heard about the other day.
Get it to the patients. But every patient with pancreatic cancer, how do I get it?
How do I get into that study? How do I get the drug?
Today's discussion, how pragmatic trials can expand reach,
lessons beyond hybrid and decentralized models,
role of community engagement and partnerships, and strategies to improve equity,
access, and representation.
So I'm going to introduce the panel,
and
we have a number of speakers. I'll introduce them now, and then
they'll come up in turn, each of them with 10 minutes to
speak, the three speakers, and then the additional panelists will each say a few
words. They'll each have two minutes to say a few words, and then we'll have about
40 minutes of a moderated discussion.
So the first speaker to talk about pragmatic trials is Constantin
Dragnev, who is the interim cancer center director and associate director for
clinical research at Dartmouth Cancer Center.
I'm actually going there to be the director, and the only downside, he's got to
remain the co-director. This guy is amazing.
So it's wonderful that Constantin, you could be here today, and I actually invited
him before I knew I was going to be the director, but it just sort of worked
out.It's true.
Next, we have Pat, because I try to divide things up.
Pat Lorusso, my dearest friend. I met Pat
gosh, 30 years ago, and we did the first trials with this drug called
ZD1839 or Gefitinib, Iressa. And Pat
is the Amy and Joseph Perella Professor of Medicine at Yale.
That's actually will become the Vince DeVita professor someday.
And she runs our developmental therapeutics and Phase 1 program, and Pat's going to
talk about hybrid decentralized trials.
And then after her, this guy, Robert Winn,
who I've been very fortunate to know.
Robert is certainly now the director at VCU,
soon to go to Fox Chase in a few months.
There's a lot out recently by Paul Goldberg in the Cancer Letter about the Cal
Breza report and where are we at. So it's wonderful that Rob's here, and Rob's
certainly been a leader in bringing trials to the community.
And then we have the WIN Program. And the WIN Program is
training diverse investigators.
So we have actually two scholars from the WIN Program here today,
Shikha and Yuwei, who are going to speak.
And then, if it isn't enough, we have two amazing experts.
We have Electra Paskett,
who's the Marian N. Rowley Professor of Cancer Research at Ohio State.
And certainly, when you think of the rural areas, you think of Appalachia and
getting trials to patients. Electra is the dean of that.
We all have her on our EABs.
So she's helped us all. And then Camille Campbell,
who's a bioformer leader. She's at Biogen now and a leader in health equity.
So wow, we have quite a panel. So I've taken too much time, and now it's my
pleasure to invite you, Konstantin, up in a pragmatic way to talk about the trials.
Good morning, and thank you, Roy, for the kind introduction.
We will work together. Thank you for inviting me to speak
about pragmatic clinical trials in action and the lessons that we learned from
Pragmatica Lung.
I'm presenting on behalf of the co-investigator of
Pragmatica, Dr. Redmond, Rekemp, Herbst, and
Gray.
These are my disclosures.
And I'll start with some definitions of how we evaluate
clinical trials.
Efficacy,
this is the extent to which an intervention is more beneficial than
harmful under ideal circumstances.
While effectiveness is whether an intervention is more
beneficial than harmful under conditions of
real, everyday practice.
Efficiency, on the other hand, this is the effect of an
intervention in relation to the resources it needs.
But for all of us, for patients, for oncologists, the key question is:
Will this treatment work for the patient that I'm seeing in the office
today?
And this is what pragmatic trials are.
They are designed
to inform decision maker about the effectiveness, the
balance of benefits, burdens, and risk of an
intervention in
routine clinical practice. This is in contrast
to the explanatory, more traditional type of trial
that tests the efficacy under ideal conditions.
So a pragmatic trial asks the question, does this
intervention work under usual conditions?
And the opportunity to use pragmatic trial approach for registrational
intents is clearly novel and potentially
paradigm changing.
Usually,
pragmatic and explanatory trials are looked at
very independently as two extremes, on one side,
pragmatic, on the other side, explanatory.
And from this figure from Lancet Oncology,
it is clear that it's a continuum. There is a lot of overlap,
and this can be on patient selection, it can be on the intervention,
it can be outcomes, whether it's very standardized,
intermediate for the explanatory or clear,
definitive for the pragmatic overall survival
versus response rate,
the data elements that are being collected, the
comparator.
So it's a continuum. There is no purely pragmatic or purely
explanatory.
The design of pragmatic trials were really
accelerated when Project Pragmatica was launched by
the FDA
at the leadership of Dr. Pozdner, who is here,
looking at functional efficiencies and enhanced patient
centricity. So the idea was to do
pragmatic trial designs that incorporate
aspects of traditional clinical trials, but with real-world
and routine clinical practice elements, depending on the
disease under question, knowledge about the treatment, and other practical and
scientific considerations.
So we launched Pragmatica Lung
S2302 as a prospective randomized study of
a chemotherapy-free regimen, ramucirumab and pembrolizumab,
versus standard of care chemotherapy for patients with previously treated
lung cancer.
This was an FDA registrational intent trial.
It emerged as a way to validate
the overall survival benefit of a smaller
randomized Phase 2 trial, S1800A, that was done
in the Lung-MAP platform.
These results needed to be validated, and we wanted to design a
pragmatic trial to reduce the burden
of clinical trial participation and to promote inclusion of all participants
with the disease. So our goals were to empower investigators
to treat patients on the trial as they would in the real world, to
decrease barriers to enrollment, and to minimize data
collection.It was a
very straightforward, simple design.
Patients with previously treated lung cancer
were randomized to receive either standard of care
or remicirumab and pembrolizumab.
Eight hundred participants were planned to be enrolled.
There was a single primary objective, overall survival, and
only two secondary objectives,
serious and unexpected high-grade treatment-related adverse events
and survival comparison by histology.
With this simplified concept,
the protocol was developed from concept to
activation in 200 days. And as a reminder,
the guidelines
recommend a target of 300 days and a deadline
of 540 days.
And the protocol
was 47 pages. Now, if we exclude
appendices, it becomes 30 pages, and this is a Phase 3
registrational intent trial. Informed consent form was 11 pages.
So these are less than half of what the smaller
randomized Phase 2 trial was.
A very short timeline. The results of the Phase 2
trial
became available early 2022. We submitted
for presentation at ASCO in February 2022.
There was an oral presentation and simultaneous JCO publication in June.
Within a month, we started talking about Pragmatic Lung.
In March of 2023, Pragmatic Lung launched, and in December of
2024, it completed accrual. This
is a very unusually short timeline for a Phase 3 trial.
The trial showed no difference in overall survival for the
chemotherapy-free remicirumab pembrolizumab combination compared
to standard of care,
with a decrease in adverse events, serious adverse
events leading to discontinuation with the chemotherapy-free
arm, and a trend towards increase in time to treatment
failure.
This
rapid design and completion of the trial was clearly
facilitated by the pragmatic design.
There were very few
limited eligibility criteria,
stage,
prior therapy, performance status, and safety in terms of ability to
receive the treatment. Patients were enrolled and treated as
we do in everyday practice. The
only recommendation was use institutional guidelines and
investigator discretion.
There was minimal items on the study calendar, no study
required labs, no imaging.
The data that we wanted to capture was minimized to
reduce the time points to be collected, the number of
forms, and the number of
data elements per form. There are
no concurrent medications being collected, and this
simplified the monitoring auditing of the trial.
We had very rapid accrual and broad
representatives as a result of the pragmatic design.
On the left is the accrual
curve. The dotted line is the
targeted accrual when we designed the trial, 29 patients per
month. And as you can see throughout the life of the trial,
we enrolled clearly more patients, between 40 and 60.
And usually, when we show graphs like this, they are reversed.
The targeted is much higher than the accrual.
And the accruals came from the entire NCTN
network of community and academic sites in
rural and urban area, not just the ivory
tower academic centers, with more than
600 sites having the study open. This led to a
very broad representativeness of the
participants that enrolled.
And our goal of reducing the burden of clinical
trial participation is very clearly demonstrated
here. This is the dramatic reduction
in the number of data elements collected at one year
and the number of forms submitted at one year
compared to the very similarly designed smaller
Phase 2, S1800A. So the design
clearly worked.
It is not a design for every trial.
We had agents with known toxicities.
The combination was already studied.
In the era of precision oncology, complex studies
typically limit patients accrual in the single trial, so we were offering a
very broad eligibility opportunities.
We had
both NCI and the FDA launching initiatives to promote
pragmatic trial design. We had very strong support from the Friends of
Cancer Research and the Foundation of NIH.
And clinical centers and research sites really
interested in finding ways to enhance patient accrual.
So what we learned from Pragmatic Lung was that patients do want to
enroll in clinical trials, but features of standard
explanatory trials often present barriers to participation.
Pragmatic Lung set a paradigm-shifting example in
trial conduct that should be applied to future randomized
trials, including those with registrational
intent.The pragmatic elements of the trial led to
faster protocol development of activation with less burden
on research staff.
Pragmatic Lung achieved rapid accrual among
representative patient population, leading to generalizable
results.
So thoughtfully including pragmatic elements in trials
will provide increased access for patients.
I would like to thank
the study participants in Pragmatic Lung, their caregivers,
the research site, as well as the FDA, NCI CTEP,
all four NCTN groups, the Foundation for NIH, Friends
of Cancer Research,
the SWOG Operations Office and Data and
Management Center, as well as Eli Lilly and Merck for
supporting this study. Thank you.
We'll take questions at the end.
And that was wonderful. That trial got
drugs to patients, and I don't see Ellen Siegel here, but call out to her and
Friends of Cancer Research for always advocating for that in her role in getting
this started. So now the second speaker today is Dr.
Pat LaRusso, as I mentioned, and she'll talk about hybrid decentralization trial
models.
Thank you, Roy. Thanks. Thank you for being here today.
I know it's one of the first sessions of the
meeting.
I'm going to talk today about hybrid decentralization of a model for early-phase
clinical trial recruitment. This project
specifically was looking at phase one clinical trial
recruitment. I must first put a shout-out to Dr.
Rick Pazdur, who's in the
audience today.
I was a fellow under Rick for four years, and
Rick was the one who got me excited and made me
realize the absolute importance of clinical research,
and thanks to him, I've been doing it ever since.
And regarding this trial, one of my
coworkers, Scott Borner,
was very instrumental in helping me advance this forward because it
took a lot of manpower. The concept is great,
but the funding is almost never there.
And so together we had to write many, many grants
to secure about $8 million so we could not only bring this
project to fruition, but also maintain it long
term.
So when I got to Yale, what I recognized was that
unlike when I was in Detroit, working in the inner city of Detroit,
there were very, very few patients that
we were able to recruit to trials that were
underrepresented. And I couldn't quite figure it out because one of the attractions
that I had when I was going to Yale was Yale had a
core center at the Yale University in Smilow.
But there were, at that time, 15 and now 18 clinics
throughout Connecticut,
Massachusetts, and Rhode Island for which we had
established clinics, but yet we weren't getting those
patients to come to trials.
So what I wanted to do was figure out a way that we could recruit
underrepresented populations, as I was very accustomed
to that population, and recognizing the
need for global representation
of underrepresented patients into our clinical trials because of the needs
to understand what an early phase trial is all about.
Pharmacokinetics, pharmacogenomics,
safety, toxicity, and by the way,
efficacy.
And so we decided we were going to move forward, and this was the mission that we
laid out: to increase accessibility for patients of all racial and
ethnic backgrounds and/or medically underserved locations
to equally participate in studies that will lead to breakthroughs in cancer
treatments that will benefit, hopefully, all patients.
We saw the statistics. Mine are a little more dim than Roy's were.
About 5% of newly diagnosed adult cancer patients usually go on to
trials.
Causes increased costs, premature study failures.
So it's not only about the patient not being served, but it's also about the
trials themselves not being served.
And more importantly, especially in phase one trials, they do not represent the
full diversity of the population, and it may lead to potential
failure because of lack of identification of
particular groups who could benefit or at least be at increased
risk for receiving those novel trials.
We know that the burden of cancer is not equally shared.
We know that in the United States,
in terms of the underrepresented population, it rep-- 13% of
blacks, 18% of Hispanics, but yet only
less than 4% of clinical trials have
underrepresentation of
underserved populations. And so there's a huge, I felt at
the time, importance of recruiting underrepresented patients
to trials because more and more what we're seeing, because
biology is driving novel therapeutics,
drugs that are actually working in early phase trials,
drugs that are actually working better than many standard of care
treatments in the advanced metastatic setting.
So this is just looking at the statistics, and as you can see, this
data goes through 2018. But what you do see is
that really there's been no real main change in
recruitment of many of these underrepresented
populations.And so how do we
achieve diverse trial representation? Collaboration is key.
Going out and talking to the clinicians at these clinics
is very important, but they're very busy.
And I did take road trips when I got there to try to make them
understand what I was trying to achieve when I was setting up the program,
and then again, as I was setting up this hybrid program years
after I got there. But you need to
involve the community in understanding and contributing to what we're doing.
But more importantly, to building the community, you need to build
trust, pivotal to
engage knowledge, as well as having the research capacity
once you begin to work together. And so we
recognized that there were four major components.
There was an individual, interpersonal level, health system and
policy level, which has been my greatest challenge,
and community level.
And so our vision was to propose a hybrid
decentralization, early phase clinical trials model,
employing a process whereby many of the components of the trial are
executed closer to the patient's home using procedures that vary from
the traditional clinical trial model whenever possible, rather than having
the patients always come to a centralized site.
We are in New Haven, and Connecticut is one of the smallest states in the
United States, and so you would think it would be a no-brainer, but it takes a
lot for these patients who have no resources.
In Connecticut, we have one of the wealthiest populations in the
country. We also, unfortunately, have one of the poorest
populations in the country. And so what we wanted to do was
expand to two
communities. Waterbury, Torrington, 30%
of the population lives below the poverty line.
Bridgeport, many of our patients that I see there don't speak
English.
Many of them, unfortunately, may not have permanent
visas.
Many of them don't have good jobs, if they have jobs at all.
And so what we've decided to do was expand.
And so I started by going to Bridgeport to be able to recruit
some of those patients, and I'll talk to you about it.
So as I said, Fairfield, Waterbury,
we didn't have any money, and although the institution really was gung ho
on getting something like this forward, they really didn't offer
the most pivotal component that is required, which is finances.
So Scott and I embarked on writing a clinical trial.
It was ironic that Gateway ASCO had a trial.
I had a grant RFP to look at recruitment of underrepresented
populations. I heard they had 400
applications, and for some reason, they chose us.
They gave one grant, and we got it. But unfortunately, they withdrew money
shortly after we got the grant because there was some political conflict
between Gateway and the monies that we were to get.
But our aims were, first, we wanted to identify what the problem was in these
communities and look at two separate communities to see if the
communities which represented underrepresented populations, but
totally different underrepresented populations, had the same
issues. So we conducted a multilevel assessment of unique
facilitators and barriers to recruitment.
And what we not only did was not only talk to the patients in both
Hispanic and English and whatever other language we
needed to be able to communicate with them, but we also looked at
provider and health system policy and community level
influences. And then secondly, which is where we are now, we wanted
to implement a sustainable program so that we could
increase recruitment of underrepresented patients to our trials and
at the same time, being able to maintain safety and data integrity
of these trials by hybridly bringing them in and then
subsequently treating them outside of the facility.
And then finally, which we haven't gotten yet, to evaluate the patient
provider health system and community partner experience so that we can
determine whether or not, globally, the community at large,
including patients and physicians, thought that this was a
productive
endeavor. So for study one, we had to include the
community outreach team at
Yale, and Jessica Lewis spearheaded this and
conducted this multilevel assessment where she did
in-depth interviews of patients, physicians,
and nursing staff, online surveys, which
included significantly more oncologists, as well as
looking at the domains. What were the social and structural
barriers that we had to face and overcome?
What we found in terms of interviewing the patients, they
wanted more information about cancer etiology, treatment options, and
trials. They wanted multimedia, multilingual,
and they wanted data and information at their
literacy level because we were dealing with many
patients that had never really graduated from middle school and
many that had never gone to school in the United States.
Patients need an invitation to trials.
The majority of patients that we interviewed, and they were all
patients that would otherwise be eligible for early phase trials,
didn't even know what they were, were never asked to
participate. Patients need help with their unmet social
needs.
Trust me, I'm finding this out. Many of these people can't come to
us. They have no transportation. They were taking the bus to the clinics.
They can't leave their mother who's dying at the age of 88,
even though they have advanced metastatic disease, because they're the only ones
taking care of them. And if they give up their job as a
bagger in the local community grocery store
making minimum wage, they have no way to feed themselves and their
family.So patients need to feel a truly positive
relationship with the health system and with research.
What we found from our providers is that it's hard for them to talk to
patients about trials. They're in community clinics.
We only interviewed providers in community clinics.
They don't have time. They have to meet their margins.
They have no support to talk to the patients.
The providers want to know patients
have their social needs met,
so a trial does not burden them. They also want
information about particular trials.
"I'm not going to send you for any trial. What are you going to give my patient?
They're going to call me, and they want to know about this drug." Staff
needs more information about early phase trials. The nurses were clueless.
Providers and staff wanted patient and community trust.
And so we embarked beginning to start
programs, bringing in community health workers to
be able to work with the patients, not only within the
clinic but also within their communities.
So for specific aim two, once we figured out what we needed, we started
going into the clinics. So I needed more work to do because doing
two clinics a week is not enough, so you got to add more clinic time, right?
But anyway, I also recruited a junior faculty, Dr.
Sooyoung Kim, to help me, who goes there with me.
And subsequently, we just opened up the Torrington Waterbury facility,
and I recruited two junior faculty who I trained over the last few
years as early phase investigators that go into
the Torrington community.
We wanted to see if we could increase recruitment and, at the same time,
maintain patient safety and data integrity.
When we went to Bridgeport-- Before we went to Bridgeport,
up to
November 1st of 2022, we got no
patients from Bridgeport. We got zero patients.
When I started this, in our early phase program, we were recruiting
2% underrepresented minority, and they were the wealthy
underrepresented minority that could actually come the distance.
I would occasionally, once I started this, start seeing patients that were
coming to me on main campus from places like
Hartford, but they couldn't figure out how they were going to get home,
and they couldn't afford to come back again. So I knew there were real barriers.
And as you can see, we significantly increased the patient
numbers over the last few years, such that roughly
22% of the patients we now recruit to early phase trials
are from underrepresented populations.
This is just looking at it. Yes, in these communities, we still saw a
lot of white non-Hispanics. However, many of these white
non-Hispanics, especially in the Torrington area, where the
vast majority of patients are Caucasian, they're
still under
the poverty line, 30%, like I said.
But we were able to get these populations that we were not seeing
previously within our program. Well, we had to
put out many educational tools. And thanks to Boehringer Ingelheim, who
gave us a grant and actually helped us publish things, we were
able to bring forth many educational tools, not only in
English but also in Spanish. And this one I'm the most proud
of. So when my kids were going to elementary school and beforehand, I
used to read them Golden Books, these Little Golden Books that were at, like,
a third-grade level. So what my team did, there were about six of
us that worked on this in conjunction with advocacy.
A lot of my patients that were on trials, I used as
advocates. What we created was a Golden Book.
It's called Myth of MythBusters.
And our Golden Book is busting myths about clinical trials.
Very simple. We took 17,
18 of the most common myths that we heard from all the
patients we interviewed,
identified the most factual information given by the
FDA, the NCI, et cetera,
dummied down the language to a third, fourth-grade level.
My daughter was a third-grade teacher in an elementary school in
South Carolina. We asked her to beta test it with her
third-grade class. Most of them could understand what they were reading,
and so we had Boehringer Ingelheim publish this as a
book that we now give to our patients.
It's in multiple languages. It represents multiple patients.
So
looking forward, as I told you, we have identified many challenges,
and I can tell you that my number one challenge is
institutional. They tell me that if I
fund and give resources to my underrepresented
patients, I have to give resources to my patient that
comes in that's a millionaire.
And that's hard for me to swallow, but we've started doing it.
The other thing is we need more navigation.
People don't recognize the importance of navigation, and it's
challenging when you're an N of one wanting to do navigation in
a large matrix institution.
But like I said, it takes a village to do a project
like this, and these are all the people and
institutions and companies that have been able to fund
me, not only to begin the project, but to be able to
maintain it for several years to come. Thank you.
Thanks, Pat. Gave you a few extra minutes because you're a former AACR president
and-
Yeah, sorry about that.
You know, Constantine reminds me we have Dr.
Seuss at Dartmouth, so we can do a book with the Grinch with you. So we're working.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I went to his museum at Dartmouth
We got our collaboration. See, enter Cancer Center.
Okay, now, for the final speech before we go to the discussion,
Rob Winn. Wow, you have a great last name for what you do.
Because he's a winner.
Community engagement, the WIN program. Robert.
Thank you, Ryan. Thank you and the committee for allowing me to do this.
I know this isn't a shout-out to Rick Pastor Day, but it is a shout-out to
Rick Pastor Day.
Sometimes we have giants in the field, and we
sometimes just don't think about them enough or don't actually just take the moment
just to say thank you. But I want to say thank you to him because what he did at
the FDA and what he's doing now, this sense of integrity, this
sense of always having a focus on the right North Star,
independent of whoever has to say anything because we know
it's right, is something, Rick, that I want to tell you, I want to thank you, and
it's been an inspiration for me throughout my career, so I appreciate that.
So, I'm going to shorten up this talk because I really want to not
dilute it by getting to the actual point.
Number one, as we talk about clinical trials, and we've
all in this room talked about the fact that we don't have rural
communities, we don't really have enough minority communities, but we just don't
have people on clinical trials the way we ought to, the way other countries are
actually starting to do it.
So I started thinking about this and this program, once I
frame it, I hope will address the why this program exists and
why community focus is at the center of everything that I
do.
I should have titled this Better Science for All, but a subtitle is Community
Engaged Cancer Research as a Driver of
Translational Impact.
Here are the three sort of tensions we have
as clinicians, as scientists, and even within our
communities. The first is the Lord Kelvin.
What is measured is known.
I'm going to put that in a category of outcomes.
Now, when I say outcomes, what I mean by outcomes is those things that
happen as a result of the actions we put in place and can be measured.
Now, the reality is that you all should know that we, at this
place, we are guilty of the sins of actually seeing
that that is "infallible."
When we think about outcomes, we also think that when we don't meet our outcomes,
what do we do? Well, there are other metrics, and so we have secondary outcomes,
and then third.
But the reality is that's not the same as impact, y'all.
Let's start thinking about this in the context of we as cancer
center directors now are talking about our catchment area and talking about the
impact we have on people. But let's not play with the word impact.
And let's get it clear that outcomes is necessary, but may not
be sufficient for impact.
Impact is, did you get the damn thing done?
Second,
we have a struggle between what's best and what's easiest.
And many of us in our institutions are dealing with the actual financial pressures.
And so there are many times we know what might be the best model,
but then we're asked to sort of consistently make
compromises till it becomes the easiest.
And just like outcomes. Outcomes are good. It gives us a structure.
It gives us something to measure. Lord Kelvin was right.
But so was Albert Einstein. I think he said that not everything that could be
measured matters and not everything that matters can be measured.
I think our communities are actually probably way ahead of us in wanting us to at
least acknowledge that there are things that can't be measured.
But as we think about impact, we do need to be clear about, agreed
upon what that actually happens. And the third is,
and I know this is the hardest for us because I came up in this culture.
The
trial legacies that people just do it because they want to leave a legacy behind.
I don't know if y'all been watching TikTok or Google or any of these other things.
That may have been something. But what really is happening
is that the reason why most people are willing to take some sort of purple juice
and all the rest of the stuff and experiment is because they want hope.
I think we need to be better about clarifying and communicating what
we mean by when you've reached the end of the standard of care.
The standard of care is access to a trial.
That's an extension of healthcare because it may either give you hope
today that it might work, we don't know, or at least hope tomorrow
that'll work for someone else. That's a lot different than saying, "I'm going to
leave a legacy."
It's in that context that we were struggling for
how could it be that we can get more people on the clinical trials, and then it
dawned on me that we have been consistently blaming the patients.
We essentially say they don't want to be on trials. That's not true.
Nadine Barrett and others have shown that sometimes you just don't ask.
Now, I know some of y'all been in middle school. I was there, too.
And when I was in middle school, I
actually had this problem that people didn't want to dance with me.
It was like that Gap song, "What you going to do with us standing up the wall?
You know you get up the..." I didn't ask because I assumed they were going to say
no. The second thing is when I did ask, in
retrospect, I probably would have said no to myself.
I also think that we need to work as a community on being
able to have a multilingual level of science so
that we make it accessible and understandable to all.
And I hope that this is what... I'm going to give you a couple reasons of what the
program we set up did. The only mistake is that,
anyways, I wish they would've called this thing something different, but they
didn't.
So,
let me
see, how do I start forward? I'm just going to do it this way.
These are my disclosures.
So
we are not training the next generation of
clinical trialists to think about doing trials.
We are training the next generationI actually think of
impact players and not just wanting to do something different but do a different
thing. When I think of clinical trials, you think of
infrastructure, but you think of people and
approaches. One of the things I recognized that while we were training people who
knew regulatory, we knew impact, that mean they knew
design, they knew implementation, they knew regulatory.
They could quote it Bible and verse, chapter and verse.
They had no freaking idea, though, that the reason why they weren't getting any
patients is because they didn't know, nor had they included or took the
time to understand that there was a science of outreach and engagement
that allows you to build upon skills to use things
like, for example, functional asset mapping at the beginning of your
trials to figure out how to get targeted groups on better.
You see, it turns out that outreach and engagement is not just a thing, it actually
is a science.
So the big, bold idea was an aha moment.
It literally was an aha moment, and I had Patty Ticos and many others, and then I
think John Damati and others who wound up getting involved in this.
It was a, wait a minute. I had this thing like, "I don't think we have
the quarterback." Now, for those of you who know me, I do my best
impersonation of trying to think about other things, but I like sports.
I can't. Science is sports. If loving both is
bad, then I guess, listen, I ain't good because I love them both.
So hang with me with the quarterback.
You need someone that can align, orchestrate,
organize, and actually have a sense of expertise in each of
the field. What we do is we have lots of
outreach engagement. People say, "Go out and do the engagement." And then we get
p****d at them when they don't really understand how difficult it is to get a
molecule to become a medicine.
Then we have all this pressure on our clinical trialist to
design, to implement the regulatory, all these other things,
and then we get p****d at them because, "Oh, well, you're not bringing minorities
in or you're not bringing..." What the hell?
You think it's just a snap of the finger.
I wish it were like a cartoon show where I could just say, "I just wanted that." It
doesn't happen because we forgot that that very act
isn't just an activity, it's a skill set and a
science of which there's now 40 years of data that we can
use frameworks to bring that in. Now, the beauty of this program
was what would happen if you trained a single person as your
quarterback to not only understand the rigors, regulatory,
implementation, design, but also at least a familiarity
with the science of outreach and engagement. Hypothesis.
Could you put more people on the trials, at-risk populations and rural
populations?
So let's get right down to it.
It was an unmet need. That's why the program came about,
and there was a not created workforce of
experts that could do both.
So we went about
having the team.
Catherine Grimes,
Bristol Myers Squibb Foundation has been there from time zero with this idea, and
I can't thank Catherine enough.
Jill, and Osa, and Lavanya from Genentech,
Amgen, Gilead, and we have our three professional bodies, the
AACR, ASCO, and AHA. But I want to tell you that
the unsung heroes in this picture you don't see them, but at least I have
my friend to my side. This guy, I think
Dr. Herbst, and Yashir right from the
beginning. We have been really struggling about
how to not just do something different, but to do a different thing, and they have
been critical to this mission. These are our partners.
It not only takes a village, but it takes professional, it takes businesses, it
takes the corporations, but it also takes community.
So these are national advisory committee, but let's get down
to brass tacks, and I'm going to just save you a minute.
I'm going to get right down to it. Let's just suffice it to say we have a rigorous
training program that lasts two years. You want to find out more about it? You can.
It is a curriculum that it's ever being refined.
Let's just say that we not only have a curriculum, but we also have a really great
start with the ACR, where we have our own week, almost like the equivalent of the
Veil Course, where difference between the Veil Course of you have to have it all
done. Sometimes we actually have people who are three-quarters of the way there,
50% of the way there, that we help them to get something that turns out to be
amazing.
Next thing is, we actually have not only our,
as you'll hear, our amazing scholars that are part of this, but we
also include med students.
And let me just get right to it. Come on y'all.
When you look at the data-- Now listen, the first pancake turns out wasn't so
bad,
but the subsequent pancakes have showed us that by literally combining the two
skill sets, that is of learning how to be a traditional clinical trialist, the
regular routines that you do through the Paul Calabresi Awards and all the rest of
these other K12s, by partnering that
and emphasizing the science of outreach and
engagement,
hands down, and we're getting together a paper to sort of put together and to
put it back in for publication. But the data is clear.
Hands down, these folks are able to actually outperform
industry standards and all other standards that have been created in the country.
Second, that the reality is, with our medical students,
61% of them have said really by being part of this program, not only do they
better understand clinical trials, but it excited them to have a career in
academics. I want to leave you with just this last thing.
Our scholars have actually been able to actually outperform
people with getting rural communities on the trials,
minorities onto trials. But more importantly, the skill sets,
as you'll hear soon, which is why I'm going to end soon,
they've been able to figure out how to advance science of clinical trials
in ways that we
are still being amazed by.
This is the future
I'll end with sort of saying that lots of grants would come out of this and lots
of things,
I mean, papers and stuff. But the thing I actually feel the most proud about,
98% of the people who've been involved with this program still are
connected several years out with community
and building those bridges. So I know there's a bunch of other slides which I'm not
going to get to because the most important thing are the two scholars that
you'll hear from, which I'm super proud about.
They're both from UCSD. Dr. Chen, I think
he's from our cohort four, and he'll get to tell you a little bit more
about himself. And she's from our cohort two.
That's going back. Those are the first two pancakes.
They wound up being, honestly, that second cohort.
The first cohort, my knees were getting wobbly, but by the second cohort, I was
like, "Okay, we got something." And so they're going to tell you a little bit more
about what they do, and I'm just going to sort of say that from this point on, as
we're thinking about trials and, quote, "solving problems," let's not get
sometimes so caught up in the weeds that we admire the problem, but we try to
actually solve the problem. And that while I love outcomes and we
need outcomes to direct, the ultimate goal is impact.
And let's quit confusing the two terms impact with outcomes.
They're similar, but they are not the same. So anyways, I'll stop there.
Thank you so much.
This is great. So now what I'd like to do is I'd like each of the panelists for two
minutes just to introduce themselves. We have our Winn scholars.
They can tell us a bit about what their project is.
Maybe we'll start out with Camille all the way on the left, and then we'll go to
Electra and just go down. And then we have a lot of questions, and I'm hoping
people will ask audience questions, too. Camille.
Thank you. Hi, everyone. My name is Camille Campbell.
I'm a pharmacist. I have worked in pharmaceutical industry or
industry adjacent for about 18 plus years in traditional
medical affairs roles, yes, as a medical science liaison.
I was a medical director at a major pharmaceutical company helping to bring to
market drugs in prostate cancer, breast cancer, pancreatic cancer.
Got very frustrated by the lack of diversity in the clinical trials and actually
left pharma for a while and did health equity and community engagement work
fully. I'm now back in pharma. I work for a midsize
biotech as a health equity director.
And my role there is to take all of the medical affairs experience and the
community engagement experience and internally help our
teams understand how health equity and clinical trial diversity
principles can be embedded across different functions, all the
way from drug development through to commercialization.
But then we also, my team, externally, we actually go out and
engage community, and we go and we talk to folks, and we bring insights
from the community back to our teams.
And also we partner with different organizations and community
partners to ensure that we're truly hearing the voices of patients,
caregivers, and communities in expanding our reach.
And so happy to be here today and to just share about my experiences.
Thank you, Camille. Electra?
Yes. Thank you for inviting me to join this such distinguished
panel here. I'm Electra Paskett. I'm a professor at
the Ohio State University. I'm also the deputy director for
Population Sciences and Community Outreach in our cancer center,
and I am the founding director of our Center for Community Outreach and Engagement.
So the principles that Rob has talked about, I
do. And I do that not only in community outreach engagement for our
cancer center, but I also do that in my research, and my
research is in population sciences all the way starting
at etiology
through to interventions from prevention, early
detection through survivorship.
And I focus most recently on rural and
Appalachian areas, which we'll talk a little bit more about.
And I got into the area of clinical trial accrual because
I've done exactly what Rob and Pat talked about, which was go to
the community, understand why they don't participate, what do they know about it,
and then design and test interventions to
increase accrual to clinical trials.
One of the things which we probably won't talk about, but I'm most proud
about is I also direct the cancer control program in Alliance that
Constantine mentioned as one of the cooperative groups.
And when Monica Bertagnolli was the chair of that group, she set a
benchmark for us to have accrual of
20% racial and ethnic minorities to both cancer
control and treatment trials. And I can tell you that for over three years
now, we have consistently accrued over 20% to both
treatment trials and cancer control
programs. And it took a village. We instituted
many, many, many
interventions in Alliance, and it's not rocket science.
It can be done if you have the will from the top, which I think
is what Pat alluded to a little bit and what is most
important. So I look forward to talking more about this.
Thank you, Electra. Chika.
Hi, my name is Chika Awajiku. I'm an assistant professor at UCSD.
I'm also a radiation oncologist. I didn't say that.
My focus is in breast and cervical cancer.
I see breast and cervical cancer patients, and most of my research is focused on
cervical cancer.
So I'm a Winn Scholar, as Dr. Winn mentioned, and I was part of the cohort
two. And essentially,
I think we're going to talk a little bit more about the program, but what the
program allowed and afforded me was a
space to sort of really develop what it means to be a clinical
trialist that's engaged in the community.
And so essentially what that meant was I was doing research in
cervical cancer. A lot of the cervical cancer patients
in the US are really underserved populations.
And for the longest time, we hadn't had real trials in cervical
cancer patients. We just hadn't changed the way we were treating these patients.
And the question was whether or not
It was because we didn't have new ideas about how to manage cervical cancer
patients, so we couldn't get them on trials.
So what the program afforded me was learning
how to go from the beginning, designing a trial that patients in the
community wanted to be a part of and to participate in.
And a lot of the things Dr. LoReuse talked about,
a lot of these patients are
from lower socioeconomic classes.
The idea of
participating in a trial for them meant that
they missed an extra day of work, not to mention the treatments they were getting.
And so a lot of the things that I learned from that program was how do
you design the trial so that it's more efficient for the patient?
How do you design the trial so that they want to participate in it?
How do they understand what the trial is about?
Is it really going to change my outcome?
And so I thought the program just gave me the space to
learn how to do those things. I can't tell you that I'm perfect at doing those
things yet.
But it did afford the ability to learn from a lot of
experts, to learn from people who had designed those kinds of trials.
The trial I worked on during the program was a phase one clinical trial,
and I remember you as part of my
advisors on that trial. So it just
gave you the space to learn how to do the things that you
hope and you want to implement for your patients, but you don't really know where
to start from and how do I approach this?
So, it was a great program. It was two years. It was intensive.
And just learned not only from the
faculty mentors, but also learned from your peers.
How are their trials going? What were the problems they were running into, and how
did they fix them? And so just a great
time all around.
Excellent. Thank you. And Yue?
Good morning, everyone. My name is Yue Chen.
I'm a genitourinary medical oncologist here at UC San Diego.
I see kidney, prostate, and bladder cancer patients in my clinic, and my research
focus is prostate and kidney cancers.
So first of all, it is my great honor to be here joining the esteemed
faculty here, to just share a little bit about my journey
participating in the WIN program.
I think
I joined as the faculty. This is my first faculty job.
I finished my fellowship at Vanderbilt, so moved all the way from Nashville,
Tennessee, to here. During my fellowship, I don't know if, Dr.
Wayne, you remember my co-fellow, Eden.
She was the very first cohort of this program, and she
introduced this wonderful program to me.
So as a faculty here, what I learned here, many of you are
aware that our main campus is at La Jolla campus, but we also
recently opened another outpatient center.
It's more closer to the downtown, which with a catchment
area, with more minority patients here, Downtown Hillcrest area.
I see patients at both sites, and what I learned in my clinical practice is that
I have many patients who come from El Centro, which is a
city, driving here about two and a half hours.
And in that area, the population is about
40,000 people living there.
But there are only two oncologists there and only one radiation oncologist
there. So many of the patients that come to us trying to
find new novel treatment options,
and through all the process, I learned how we can mitigate,
engage the communities, getting more trust in terms of clinical trials,
because many of our patients they are
really skeptical about clinical trials.
What I have been learning through all this process is that our
disease program, we have annual
patient summit specific for example, prostate cancer patient summit,
bladder cancer patient summits, and kidney cancer patient summits.
We invite our patients who are on clinical trials to share their
experience. As you can imagine,
hearing directly from the patients, learning about their experience
participating in clinical trials, I think that's tremendous,
impactful, and to convince other patients to sign up for
more clinical trial opportunities.
And I think throughout this program, this is something I feel like I didn't get a
chance to learn really during the fellowship program. Right?
So there are more opportunities to engage the communities, to
empower the providers, as well as
engage the caregivers and to provide the trials in the
community settings. So thank you, Dr. Wayne, for this program.
Excellent. So now we have about 45 minutes for questions.
We have two microphones. I also have questions on here.
I just want to start, and I'll tell the panel that at the end, we'll have a
lightning round. I'm going to ask you your final thoughts for how we're going to
improve things. So just keep that in your mind.
But I just want to start with the two scholars, and thanks for being here.
And how many scholars have graduated now, Robert?
Over close to 321.
Right. And we happen to have two from San Diego. It's close.
But tell me about protected time. We're in a tough time.
I see the incoming AACR president here.
We talked at a meeting yesterday at the SPGA about how
funding and NCI, NIH, K awards are hard
to find. You've each had 40% protected time through this
public-private partnership, the industry and the institutions.
Has that been important? I have a little loaded question there. Yue?
Yeah. No, so short answer to that, it's extremely important.
As a very junior faculty, just started, they're
trying to figure out where is the resources, trying to establish in a new
city that I just joined as a faculty, trying to learn more about the community,
trying to engage more patients. But at the same time, you also need the protected
research time, right, to really focus on academic scholarly
work, including grant writing, manuscript writing, as well as get a chance to
attend conferences. So I would say the protected time is huge, is
tremendous for junior faculty.
Great. Shikha?
Yeah, I totally agree.Sure. Yeah.
When I first started, I started
now six years ago, my faculty position.
And you say, "Yeah, I'm going to get a grant," and
your department has to sign paperwork to
say they're going to
allow you that protected time when you get the grant.
And sometimes that doesn't always happen.
But
this program essentially allowed us to say, "Well,
this program has given you protected time, and
also it's giving you salary support," so that time that
you're out of clinic because you're hired as a clinician, at least I was hired as a
clinician. You're hired as a clinician, but then I'm bringing this
amount of money for salary support, and so the
department essentially can't say or can't really argue that you
have the funding, and so they give you that time to do the things that you're
supposed to do to be able to figure out my trial, figure
out,
like you said, how do you engage your community? How do you work on the things?
How do you work on the scholarly things that you want to work on?
So the protected time was really helpful.
And not only that,
I don't know how far you are in your program, but we had
three hours of intense lectures where we learned all sorts
of things, from statistics to community engagement.
And if you didn't have that protected time, there's no way,
as a busy clinician, you could sit in those lectures.
And so it was really, really important.
It was really, really critical
to have that stated in the program for us to be able to do that,
for us to be fully engaged in the program.
Excellent. And that's the AACR part, the first week.
Everyone hears about the Vail course, now we have this course, and I don't know why
every cancer center doesn't send 10 people to apply, and the word's getting
out. I want to ask two questions to Camille and Electra, and then I'm going to open
it up wide, but I want to give them a chance to expand on some things.
So Electra,
I need to learn this. I'm moving up to Appalachia, the Appalachian Trail.
What is Appalachia? What is rural?
How does rural differ from more poor, socioeconomically disadvantaged?
Are they the same? Are there different issues?
And Constantin, you might want to add to this as well. Electra?
Yes. So Appalachia is a federally designated
geographic area along the Appalachian Mountains.
It extends across 13 states in the United
States, 420 counties. I cannot tell you how many
people I've encountered in my professional
experience where I'll start talking about Appalachia and they say,
"Oh, I didn't know I was from Appalachia."
And so it is a geographic region, and rural
counties are defined also geographically.
There's the RUC code, the RUCA code, there's all different types of codes.
But it's basically how far away you are from a major
metropolitan area.
So, that means there's less access
to
doctors, hospitals, oncology care.
In Appalachian Ohio, which are 32 of our 80
counties, we have about seven counties have no hospital.
And
there is no GYN oncologist in Ohio
except in the big cities, Cleveland, Columbus,
and
Cincinnati, or they go to West Virginia.
So the other thing is poverty in Appalachia, and
also we see that in rural areas. In rural areas, it's long
distances to travel, and as I was told
by a primary care doc, we don't have Ruber,
rural Uber
in the rural areas, and there's no buses.
In the urban areas, you might have to take three
buses to get to your care, but there's no buses
in the rural areas, and so transportation is a huge thing.
And
I mentioned poverty. People are working sometimes two and three jobs,
including bagging groceries as one of the three jobs.
We had one county in Appalachia that didn't have a grocery
store for four years.
No grocery store for four years, and they had to drive to
Athens County, 45 miles round trip, to get their
groceries. They had the little mini marts with gas stations,
but not really healthy food. So
there's lots of issues, and if you just think
rural has issues, Appalachia just
adds issues. We've actually looked at the cancer
incidence and mortality rates, and we find that they are
increased in Appalachian areas compared to rural
areas because of the poverty and all
of the other areas. There are also
structural issues, roads, for example.
When I first moved to Ohio, I would go, I'd say, "Well, it looks like
you can just go like this to get there." And they're like, "No.
You can't go like the crow flies. You have to follow the roads around the
mountains." And when we were doing some of our studies, my interviewers
couldn't go to women's homes to do the interviews because there had been a
storm, and a tree ran across their dirt road, and they
couldn't get in or out of their driveway until somebody came with a
chainsaw to cut the tree down for them to get in and out
of their community. There's also an aspect in
Appalachia of,
they've been taken advantage of by big
business. So maybe you heard of fracking, but another thing that
happened was that the big companies would come in
to these small farmers, and they'd say, "We'll pay
you dollars for the mineral rights
under the topsoil." Right? So they'd come in, and they would take all the
minerals from underground, and then they would leave.
And so can you grow in crops?
No.So they got the fast money, but in
the long run
they were stuck. And the last thing,
as we're driving down Appalachia a few years ago, one of my colleagues said,
"Stop, stop." I'm like, "Okay, okay.
What?"
"There's an outhouse there, and it's really being used."
And then just to leave you, I can take you if you want to come with me.
I'll take you to Quaker City. The minute we get off the highway, there is no cell
service the entire time we're there, and this is 2026.
And our mobile mammography, we take the mobile mammography out
because they have no hospital. Remember I told you we take it there regularly.
They almost did not go because they couldn't get a signal.
I said, "You are not going to say no to my people in
Quaker City. You are going to do the old way if you need
to," which was the batch reading, right?
And so they got a mobile hotspot to do it.
We take now our lung van out. We've just
gone a few times, and we've already detected two
early-stage lung cancers.
Incredible.
These people are now treated and disease-free.
But we have to go to the community. We have
to understand where they're coming from.
And I don't use the word cancer when I go.
It's lung screening, breast screening, not cancer, because cancer is a
death sentence. Because everybody they know with cancer dies.
Right.
So anyway, sorry.
No, that's amazing. And imagine how it is in sub-Saharan Africa and other countries
and globally. So this is a major worldwide issue.
So I'm so happy that you're on the panel.
And then Camille, before we start the open questions, I just want to give you a
little shout-out. The work you do in so many different organizations and community
recruitment and engagement, can you just give us a little bit of
an example of what you
do
in the company to try to help that?
Sure. So I love what you were just talking about in terms of
going out and doing screening. There's so much value
in engaging community and getting to know
community members, patients, caregivers, healthcare providers who live in the
community before you, quote-unquote, "meet them for a clinical
trial."
And that's super, super valuable and super important.
So one of the things that I've been able to do with the organizations that I have
worked in is to do just that,
and build trust through showing up time and
time and time again, whether that's through screenings, whether that's through
education around clinical trials.
Because again, at some point, you're going to want to, if you're a pharmaceutical
company, go back and offer an opportunity.
You want people to at least have a
baseline knowledge of what is clinical research and be open to engaging and
talking to you about that opportunity.
But no one's going to do that if the first time they ever see you is when you come
in and say, "I need to recruit patients for a study, and I got to hit certain
numbers," right? People can feel the vibe when
you're coming to them because you need something versus
showing genuine care. And so that's something that
I'm able to do in my current organization, I've been able to do in prior
organizations, is to go out and build community trust,
and then partner with pharmaceutical companies or research entities who
are looking to, at some point, enroll in clinical trials.
And something that
my former colleagues and I used to talk about were the different types of trust,
too, because there are multiple types of trust, and we always talk about trust,
trust, trust. We like to say cognitive trust and affective
trust. And a lot of times what we as healthcare providers
or we as pharmaceutical industry
employees have done is leaned really far into cognitive trust when
trying to engage communities. And that's trust that's based on the data and
the logic and, "You should want to participate in the study because the phase one
data supports that it could be valuable to you." And that's great, but we
really need to swing the pendulum back to also focusing on affective
trust, which is the trust that you build when you just care about people.
Showing genuine care and wellbeing.
And folks often have this very negative view of
pharmaceutical industry, right? We're big, bad pharma.
But when they see you coming into their community and investing,
asking them questions, asking them, "What is it that you really need?
What would make you want to participate?
What about screenings and things like that?"
Then it helps to build affective trust and showing that you just
genuinely care.
And you really need that balance of affective and cognitive trust in
order to later on down the road, be able to offer a
clinical study that someone would actually want to engage with
you on and potentially participate in.
So that's some of the work that I'm able to do.
That we've built trust and, Pat, with your program, you're going
out to the community for trust. Rob, the work you do, and the scholars now.
You've got 400 emissaries out there building trust in the community.
And patients need to trust, and it's a big deal to go on trial.
So now, I'm not going to script it. I think we'll go to the questions
in the audience. For the panel, I'm standing here.
Raise your hand and I'll call on you.
So we have about 30 minutes, so please go ahead.
Hi. Good afternoon. My name's Maria Berkeley.
I'm a PhD student candidate and I'm a nurse
navigator. And so my first question is for anyone
at the front who is comfortable
answering. So we primarily talked about clinical trials today.
Can you speak to the representation in general clinical
research across the board? Are we seeing that kind of underrepresentation?
And then my second question is for Dr. Lorusso.
You mentioned navigators. Can you talk a little bit about the types of navigators
that you leveraged for your team to achieve the success it
did?
It looks like Rob wants the first and then Pat the second.
Why don't you talk about representation in the clinical workforce?
Representation in the clinical workforce, we got to do better.
As many of you know, there were things underway to
be able to promote that.
That certainly is more challenging in
2026 than it was in 2022.
Having said that, the absolute truth is that
I think that I have reframed
that from talking about just having
a diverse group of people because it feels
nice as opposed to a diverse group of people because they bring something to the
table, because we're looking at impact.
For example,
what I've learned in
some of the programs that we put together is that young people,
particularly from certain backgrounds, are bringing an additional
expertise and an additional knowledge, cognitive
knowledge about how to approach a particular problem
because of their lived experience.
So I think that the truth of the matter is like any North Star.
We have made the biggest gains when there is all
of us. There is only one team with one fight, and my fight's against
cancer.
My fight's against chronic disease.
And so I think that we'll continue to drum that beat.
And the truth of the matter is, I keep telling people, "I don't know why y'all keep
getting discouraged." The truth of the matter is, if you weren't the person to get
discouraged, then... I don't know if you remember that Joshua fought the Battle of
Jericho.
Imagine being given, instead of talking about leaning into your
science and just doing more and leaning into your science, you were given
essentially a trumpet that says, "Run around this place" until the building fell
down. You can imagine the amount of saying, "Well, what do you
mean?" But that was the assignment.
What I'm telling young people and all of us is, we know our freaking assignment.
Science continues to move forward independent of typically even the
processes over time. The arc of science is forward.
And so this context of losing faith and being discouraged, I'm like,
"Dude, grip up. Know your North Star, lean
into it, and let's just go."
Yeah.
We've had people way before us during Jim Crow.
My grandmother's 99. She's a living example of what happened under Jim Crow,
and yet we were able to continue to advance science.
Our job is to know our freaking assignment. Everyone wants to do other assignments.
Do your damn assignment. Be the best scientist, be the best academic, be the best
administrator that we can. Continue to let's move this forward.
That's the only answer I think I have.
Mm-hmm.
And it's one that's time tested.
Pat?
Thank you.
Before I talk about what I'm looking for in a navigator, of the three
junior faculty that I've recruited so far, one is a WIN graduate,
one is a WIN student, and one is a WIN applicant.
Got it.
Because they all understand the importance, and they're all
multilingual, and all of them, at minimum, in addition to English, speak
Spanish.
And we had many more applicants from Yale. They don't all get in. Very competitive.
Yeah, they don't all get in. I'm lucky I get them because it helps
me give them protected time.
But the physicians I need, because of where we're going,
and so many of those people speak only Spanish, need to be
fluent in Spanish. What I'm looking for in a navigator,
what the navigator role is, and I think it's not unique
to clinical research. I think it's unique to just helping
people overcome the social and structural determinants of health.
And I need a navigator who can understand where those
resources are
or help me spend the money that I have to be able to obtain
those resources to give back to the patients.
Sometimes we're challenged. So for instance, we had a patient
who was not a legal immigrant, and so she was
deathly afraid of putting her daughter into daycare
because she was afraid because of situations that I don't
really need to go into, but we're all understanding.
So I talked with my nurse to multiple
churches that I could trust
to find a church member who would come
and help us with her patient, with her daughter,
so that she could actually get treated on a Phase I trial.
It took a lot of phone calls to find, and you needed to know what
churches you were able to trust. Thank God one of my other
Phase I investigators is also a minister.
Mm-hmm.
And he was able to, in the end, I didn't
think of him until the end, but was able to help us.
And those are the kind of things, it's not just about helping them get
a gift card to go to the grocery store.
It's about how are we going to get them to the grocery store?
Yeah.
Recently, I had a patient that came to me, an underrepresented
patient, a week ago. Actually, I was in Tucson
just before I came here, and I got a call because we couldn't get an Uber to go
there because this person lived in the middle of nowhere.
So I said, "Okay, just get him a taxi."
Mm.
Now I'm
in trouble because the taxi ride is $800 each way
because nobody wants to go there. So I'm like, "Why did these
companies give me all this money to help me get this
patient on trial? I'm going to pay the $800 each way." The first one, I
had to pay on my own Visa because my institution would not allow
us to bill for an $800 taxi ride, but I got that taken
care of, and they're going to pay me back.
Because this happened on Tuesday, I'm not going to fork the bill.
I have $8 million waiting to help fork the bill, so we're working
on the challenges of... Yeah, but navigators are so
important for every part of what we do if we're going to
make an impact here.
So am I to understand you have one nurse navigator, or do you have
other disciplines on that team?
Yeah.
Social work-
Believe it or not, I'm very, very lucky.
I have a phenomenal team, and
I have. In fact, I was just reading the Press Ganey scores
that came to me this week from last month.
And over and over again, my patients tell me in the
Press Ganey scores, they don't tell me this, one of the things they like is that we
have continuity of care.
The nurses I hired in my Phase One unit 12 years ago,
many of them are still there. I just had to hire more.
Mm-hmm.
Same with my nurse practitioners.
I am very, very, very blessed.
All of them help out, but we're all getting really busy because
when I started, we were putting a few patients a month on.
Roy knows, we're putting 25 to 30-plus patients a month on study now.
Phase One.
We've grown, yes. Only Phase One. So, we're not a
huge place. We get, I don't know, 3,000 or 4,000 analytic cases a year.
Roy would know that better than me.
But I get a lot of referrals from a lot of places.
Mm-hmm.
So everybody helps out, but we all recognize that we
need that additional navigator.
Okay. We should move on, but it's clear when you have good navigation-
Yeah
... an investigator with a big heart and a good team,
teamwork's important, and it starts at the top, right? So Camille.
Just wanted to highlight the importance of workforce representation on the industry
side as well.
And people, it can sometimes take courage to do this
work,
working in the corporate environment.
But there are so many lived experiences that all of us have, that when we
bring that thinking to the protocol development or to the community
engagement or to how we're going to market the product, it makes everything
more equitable. Um, and so I just wanted to highlight
that fact. Um, and thinking about doing things differently than maybe you
typically have done it as a pharmaceutical company based on that lived experience,
um, and being open to new ideas. One of the cool things about my team at my
current company is that we're bringing on interns in co-op
roles this summer focused on rural health,
next-gen communication. So literally having interns from Gen
Z and Gen Y, because the way we communicate
with our younger community and patient populations is maybe very
different than how we've been communicating with our baby boomers or more so the
millennials, and we need to understand those things.
So as an industry, being open to those new ideas and bringing new
lived experiences to the drug development and commercialization process.
Great, thanks. Yes, please. Sorry, Constantin.
Just a follow-up question on the navigation, because we are struggling
to set up probably the right balance navigation for
just standard of care for the routine care versus navigation for
clinical trials. And if you separate these two,
you're kind of enhancing the gap, and
you have to include research as part of the
routine navigation. And
this is, we're trying to get it, and maybe if you have examples of how you've
accomplished it.
It's a great point. Actually, while you're at the mic, tell us a little bit for the
pragmatic trial, was it really easy to get all the investigators and the companies
to agree to slim down the trial, the number of pages, the number of
tests, or was there some resistance?
So ironically,
we got more resistance from industry than
from the FDA.
What?
Because industry said, "Well, how can we not collect Grade
1 events for the life of the trial? We've always done that.
We have whole departments that are set up
to do that."
And we had to reassure them that, "No, it's okay to not
collect them." So, it was a learning curve.
So Rick, if you were at the FDA now and had the trial, had a positive result, would
it have gotten approved? Uh...
Rick used to pull his hair out. I want him to speak. Everyone mentioned him.
I wanted you to hear Rick Pazdur. Rick.
One of the things I think is important, the pharmaceutical industry said,
"Well, although you may accept this, the other
regulatory agencies, i.e., Europe, Japan, et cetera, will not
accept this."
Wow.
So what I did to preempt them, I actually went physically
to these other agencies, and we had discussions about this, and there was
really uniform acceptance of this idea.
Obviously, the one thing that we really have to push on, this was a
very good case here. However, we have had very
few takers of subsequent pragmatic trials, and I think
it's important that although this was a fully pragmatic trial,
there are pragmatic elements that could be embedded in many, many
clinical trials, and it's really moving the
pharmaceutical industry to realize that they don't need
to collect everything. For example, even with novel drugs, it might
be appropriate to collect
all the adverse events in selected groups of
institutions, rather than in every
institution, and really to focus on
issues that will really stream down clinical trial and
clinical trial cost, I think.
Rick, while you're there, just quick question.
Don't other diseases have more pragmatic trials?
Like if you have a stroke patient, they have to make a decision in the ambulance
what to do.
Yes.
Or in the ICU.
Yes. Uh-huh. And here again, we have been our own worst enemies in
oncology of wanting all of this data.
And you did mention, somebody mentioned my
phrase about hanging Christmas tree ornaments on clinical trials.
And we really had to beat back the investigators as well as
the drug companies that wanted to add quality of life.
Why can't we look at response rates? Why can't we look at this?
Why can't we look at this? And really, we had one central question
to ask, and is there a survival advantage with this-...
new therapy. And a negative trial does not mean that it
is a negative trial. It means that the results are negative.
The reason why we did this trial, and I think it's important, was
one of the drug companies, on the basis of this very small
original trial, wanted us to approve that combination.
And they were saying, "Well, you people are being over-regulatory,"
and we really did not feel that it was adequate because it
wasn't appropriately set up to test the
hypothesis, I should say. And lo and behold,
when we did the trial, it did not demonstrate what the original trial
showed, and I think that would've been a gross error that we would have
approved something that should not have been approved, basically.
So a negative trial is of importance.
Done quickly. Thanks, Rick. Okay. Let's try to get as many questions as we can in.
You've been standing a long time. Thanks for your patience.
Mark Malkin, neuro-oncologist and clinical trialist at the Cleveland Clinic,
formerly at VCU Massey. I don't have a question.
I have a few comments. Cut me off when I exceed my time.
The first thing to Dr.-
Depends on what the comments are going to be.
All supportive.
The first to Dr. Paskett's point, my colleague, Dr.
Melissa Lucas, is from Gallipolis, Ohio,
at the Ohio-West Virginia border.
There is no Aldi there. It closed.
Yep.
You know where they shop for groceries? Walmart.
And when I asked Alyssa where the nearest Costco was, she wasn't sure.
She's not.
Maybe Columbus.
Yes, probably.
This is a huge problem.
Mm-hmm.
When I was recruited at Cleveland Clinic almost four years ago, Liliana Angelov
asked me,
"How will you decide what clinical trials to stand up?"
And I told her, "Lily, it will depend on the diseases you see."
There is no point standing up a clinical trial for
oligodendroglioma if your institution, for whatever reason, doesn't see them.
No reason to do it for primary CNS lymphoma if they're all going to Memorial Sloan
Kettering to see Lisa DeAngelis.
So you want, to Rob's point
of setting yourself up for success, not failure.
We, like you, like Dartmouth, have affiliates all over the
world, actually.
And from time to time, our folks in Weston ask us if they can join
our clinical trials. They have a neurosurgeon there who operates on
brain tumors and aneurysms in spine and peripheral
nerve, and they have no neuro-oncologist.
It would be dangerous to stand up clinical trials in
that setting.
So when they build out their infrastructure,
then, of course, we'll do it.
And the other thing is, just
because there is a sexy idea that you hear about
at this meeting or at ASCO or at SNO doesn't mean that you
need to do it if you don't have the resources to do it.
Set yourself up for success.
We should celebrate what Dr. Lorusso has done
because it is a model for the rest of us in this room to do the same thing.
So when I was at VCU Massey,
I recognized that we had brain tumor
patients in the South Hill area, halfway between us and Duke,
who would be candidates for clinical trial.
But brain tumor patients have seizures, they can't drive.
Horrible.
They have visual field defects, they can't drive.
And yes, the family member is bagging groceries at Food
Lion and can't drive them because that's where they're
getting their benefits from.
So working with Rob, and we met monthly,
and with our department,
I started a clinic in South Hill,
where we have a medical oncologist, a radiation oncologist, an infusion room,
a nurse practitioner, and a clinical trial nurse.
And we started off with a half day
on a Wednesday, once a month. And it quickly became a half
day Wednesday every other week, a half day Wednesday every
week, and when I left, it was every Wednesday.
And why does Willie Sutton go to the bank
to rob for money? Because that's where the money is.
And we have to convince our administrators that it makes sense to
drive 85 miles down to South Hill and beat out the competition at
Duke, apologies to any of you from Duke,
right,
and have our nurse practitioner cover us on Wednesday when I'm
down there so that I can bring patients on clinical trials, and you start with
something easy, NRG-BN011, newly diagnosed,
methylated glioblastoma, temozolomide oral drug
versus temozolomide with lomustine oral drug.
And the other thing is, you can do most of a neuro exam
virtually.
And if you've got your nurse practitioner there, the three of you are
on a
Zoom screen. She could be doing the exam that you're observing.
And to Electra's point about no
internet, we had people come
to South Hill, where we had internet because they didn't have
internet where they were.
So what Dr. Lorusso has told us about today is
doable, folks. It's doable.
Okay. Why don't we end on that? But you can be on next year's panel.
Yep.
And the end-
Roy, can I-
I paid him to say all those things.
Roy, can I make one point?
Yeah.
So thank you for the shout-out for Gallipolis.
Mm-hmm.
But I
hope everybody here heard the important part that he said,
which is we've been talking about patients not being asked and the
patient not wanting to go on trial, but that is not the number
one reason that people don't go on trial.
The number one reason people don't go on trial, and this has been in published
papers, and a shameless plug for the next session at 12:30,
which I am chairing on the CUS2CT
Initiative, which I'll go through the whole model we designed
But the number one reason people don't go on trial is you don't have a trial for
them.
Right.
That is the number one reason. And so what you said goes back to Rob's
principle about community, understanding your community, who walks in your
door. You don't have a trial. You want to do all the boutique trials where your
patients aren't going to qualify because the eligibility criteria are too high.
Mm-hmm.
Okay? Number one, you don't have a trial.
Number two, they don't qualify because of the eligibility criteria that we keep
putting in trials.
My final point-
I'm going to have to cut you off. I'm sorry, because we've two more que-- But come
by at the end, and I really do want to put you on a panel next year.
Yes, please.
Thank you. Yes. I'm Paula
Raska. I have my own LLC now. It's called Community
Empowerment Through Health Information, or CEPHI.
Wow.
And I wanted to see what people thought of the fact that...
Well, first, I want to say,
how much do you think all of this is caused also
by a fundamental misalignment with what we consider
powerful inference and the gold standard,
this concept of clean
data, right? That's like we want
standardization. That's what leads to centralization.
And I'm very excited because
trying to argue with
pharma and industry and those that have power
inside
the ecosystem about powerful inference, now
the whole thing is changing because powerful inference is going to come from what
we consider messy data. So if we want to model patient
trajectories the way LLMs have been constructed, large
language models, through next token prediction, what we need is more
data and messy data. And so the paradigm of
having to have centralized, standardized ways
of collecting data for our sort of reductionist framework,
the clinical trial, which we consider gold standard, all of that is going to
be swept aside. And really, the patient is the
key join for all data produced
longitudinally. So even just
from the paradigm of what gives the most powerful inference,
we're going to have to be switching, and pharma and all the
institutions, they're going to have to be switching from clinical trials to
really patient-centered, patient-engaged data
collection on a longitudinal basis.
That's a great question.
So yeah. And just one more thing, because,
Robert, when you mentioned
having patient engagement at a scientific level, right,
and having multilingual scientific levels, right?
That's another thing that's up and coming with AI.
The gatekeeping of understanding and knowledge and research is no longer
there, right? People want to understand and
conduct science themselves. I don't care how low
in resources you are. We don't have to dumb things down.
People want to understand their disease and where it's going, and they want to be
able to participate in research in a real way.
I don't care what their level is, right?
So I feel that these things that are changing because of
AI are going to be changing the landscape here of what
we need to do to really engage patients.
Yeah. That's a wonderful comment. Konstantin, do you want to say a word?
Was the data messy in the Pragmatic trial?
What did the randomization do to make things work out?
Were you missing points that...
Sorry, I have to go to the next one.
Okay, Pat has another talk. Thank you, Pat.
Okay.
So it showed that you can get your primary
objective solved easily.
The difficulty was with not collecting all the
details that if the trial had a negative outcome,
then you cannot analyze, you cannot do subsets, you cannot
do hypothesis generation. So it is a balance.
For example, if Pragmatica was designed as a non-inferiority trial, it
probably would have met it, but it would have been very
difficult to do a Pragmatic non-inferiority.
Right.
But there are trade-offs.
Absolutely. Two more questions, then we're going to go to my lightning round.
Why don't we go to this microphone first, and then you'll have the next one.
Thank you. I'm Mei Lan. I'm a biomarker scientist.
Thank you for taking care of the patient at the front line, and thank you for
sharing. Again, to understand more about the challenge of
enrolling patients. So my question is,
as a oncologist or
some people working at the front line, how you
weigh the burden of a biomarker screening for the patient
enrollment against the potential of a
higher chance for better matching or also better
chance to help patient
with better efficacy and also less
toxicity. Thank you.
Once at the role of biomarkers.
So the quick thing is we suck at it.
Listen, and I mean that because we
have misaligned
the actual activity of how do we get biomarkers to our
patients.
Our primary care docs, typically, for me, in rural
populations or in some of my populations throughout the Commonwealth of
Virginia, that work isn't just done by oncologists.
That work could be done by all of us.
We don't see it that way. Second,
I actually think, and again, not to... Because I know we're running on time.
This is a conversation that I think you'll probably hear coming up in multiple
senses. Because we are underutilizing the biomarker panels
Those are being underutilized, particularly for at-risk populations.
That's been written about not just by us, but by many people, even in the popular
press with "New York Times." That is something that we're going to have to think
about. That's a structural issue.
That's a
get it done issue.
Thank you for raising that point because, I don't think we have a very good
answer at the moment.
We've been bringing this up in the Commonwealth of Virginia, just like colorectal
screening, about
appropriate biomarker testing for our rural and at-risk populations.
And that's something we introduced this year.
I don't know if it'll pass or not, but that's something that we need to be thinking
about more robustly.
Great. Thanks. Two more questions, then I want to get to the final comments.
Sure. I'm going to break this down into three quick.
Stage four cancer survivor, Sarin Rothberg, host of "Beating Cancer
Daily" in 144 countries. I'm going to go
football first with Dr. Winn. I'm a Philadelphia
Eagle. I want to-
Go Birds.
Yeah.
Change as quickly as-
I'm going to give you a Vince Papale reference, which is going to
go over most people's head. Can I be a walk-on?
You can answer that later. I want to be a walk-on to your program.
Okay. That's number one. Number two, no one
addressed paying, right? About paying for
people to come to clinical trials, and I know that it's
impoverished areas, so I wanted to find out about that.
Please answer for Pat Larusso, because I was curious of
everyone's answer here. And then the second one is, gosh, the
elephant in the room, and I didn't hear it one time.
She kind of said it for a second.
How are we using AI? And I know that a
lot of these people don't have mobile possibly, don't have computer,
but just from your side, because I'm an AI expert,
how are you using AI in healthcare to help with
advancing clinical trials?
First of all, thank you for that question and for being here as a patient.
My last question was going to be how to realistically-
33 years
So my question was going to be to the panel, so everyone can take a shot at this.
How are we going to ensure the next generation of clinical trials truly reflects
and serves all patients? Which is what you're basically asking.
How do we get these patients? How do we pay for them?
Let me ask our scholars first. You're our future here.
What do you think? K**e, you want to tell us?
How do we pay for these trials? How do we make sure that patients can get on the
trials? K**e, why don't you start?
So it depends on the type of trial. So at my stage, we do a lot of
investigator-initiated trials.
And so that means they were applying for funding, whether it be like
R21s from the NIH or it be industry-supported funding.
And so
one of the things that these funding mechanisms do is
pay for the actual trial. So that means like your clinical trials
office, your coordinators, the regulators, and those sorts of things.
And then the
concern that some patients have is how do I get from my house to the trial, or
how do I pay for childcare on that day?
And you can also apply for...
At my prior institution, we had applied for a grant from the ACS
to pay for non-trial related
expenses for patients. And so it would pay for things like transportation
for patients who couldn't afford it.
So it really depends on the type of trial you're doing.
We have cooperative group trials right through NRG and through
SWOG, I think one of the trials was
from different foundations. And so
that funding mechanism, and it depends on what you write into the
trial, that funding mechanism pays for your typical clinical
trial agenda.
And finding funding for those non-clinical trial things
is tough, but I think people are starting to talk about it.
And I think you can actually now apply for grants
from industry to actually... When you write an industry
supported grant, you can ask for that as well.
I don't think we're quite there yet because we're
now talking about all of the barriers for patients to get to trials.
And so
I think that when you're applying for your trial or you're
applying for funding, you have to think about those things.
How am I going to pay for this trial to get the patient actually on the trial?
And then how am I going to pay for all the non-trial related things?
And so-
But are you incentivizing patients by paying them?
That's what in the impoverished areas.
We do.
Yeah.
Electra.
So we do. Now, I don't do drug
trials, right? I do behavioral trials.
And we write in our NIH grants,
incentives in the form of gift cards.
And it is to Walmart,
because that's what's in the area.
So they fill out a survey online,
we'll mail them a $10 gift card. So
yes, we try to. But I think what you're hearing is that
the constraints for the funders really
don't allow us to do it. I have some industry
studies, and we also are constrained by what we can give.
And your institution has rules.
Mm-hmm.
Rules
about even giving out the gift cards.
And the government has rules. You can't write off a charge for a patient.
Right? How do you do it, Constantin?
Oh, no, this is hard. We
don't struggle. We have to comply with the IRB saying, "Well, if you're going to
pay, you have to pay for everybody," as Dr.
Larusso said, for somebody who is 30% below the poverty
line as well as the millionaire. And this doesn't make sense.
So Pat gets so frustrated with this.
So she was willing to pay for herself, and she has.
That's not a solution for the whole population, but that's a caring person and
human being. But we've got to do better here.
But we have money that we can't use because there are regulations, institutional
stipulations, but this is something that there needs to be some sort of committee
that looks at this. Any other comments?
Rob, you want to say anything before we move on to the next question?
No, I was just going to say real quick, because your second part was about AI.
This is the quick one I want to say about AI.
Let's not get so fooled that AI is the panacea.
Mm-hmm.
AI, by the way,
is, when used as the crutch
Usually winds up being very bad for all of us.
When used as a tool-
Mm-hmm
... it can be really good. But most of us, even in our communities, aren't
being taught about how to refine our approaches to use it
as a tool. And the last thing I'll say, because I know there's only-
You should've been in my session at 8 o'clock
... The only other thing I would say, there's so much talk about intelligence that
we're forgetting to talk about the pragmatic concept of
wisdom.
Yeah.
There's a lot of artificial intelligence, but intelligence actually doesn't do
you any real good and can cause harm without this
overarching sense of wisdom.
Agree.
Concrete wisdom. We are looking at governance as a substitute
for being wise about how to apply it, when to apply it, et cetera.
So I think that there's another conversation in the AI space around not
just artificial intelligence, but absolute wisdom that we should be starting
to have, too. Scientific wisdom.
That's beautiful. Yeah, I was going to say the same thing.
If you have the trust and you have the infrastructure and you have the trials,
AI can maybe enhance it. But I see all these institutions now paying millions of
dollars for triomics, for this and that. It's not going to do it.
You got to have the grassroots first in my opinion.
Thank you so much, and thanks for being here.
One last question, then we'll wrap up. It's been a wonderful session.
Really, really great. You have the last words here.
Thank you. So I'm Chu-Chen Hong. I'm from Roswell Park in Buffalo, New
York.
So my own background is in breast cancer epidemiology.
I do a lot of survivorship cohort type of work.
But right now we're trying to design a pragmatic trial
involving recruitment of
metastatic breast cancer patients across five cancer registries
in New York State. This is for a PCORI grant.
And I was wondering if the panelists could speak a little bit about how they
involve their stakeholders, like the patients and the caregivers
within their research to keep them
engaged, to help recruitment,
dissemination.
Okay. You've asked the perfect last question.
Okay.
So anyone who wants to comment, how do we do patient-centered care? What is that?
And Electra's got her hand eagerly up.
Yeah. So, all of our work, we always have community advisory
boards. In actually our cancer center, we have a community advisory board.
So for the population that you're working with, you should get some
sort of a consumer board or patient board or something.
And we
did a study, this was a point I wanted to make because we haven't talked about
truly remote studies. We've talked about pragmatic,
decentralized, but we haven't talked about remote.
So I am also a population scientist.
We did a truly remote study
in... I recruited about 1,000 rural,
100% rural women from 98 rural counties in
Indiana and Ohio.
Mm-hmm.
I recruited them through Facebook, and they were all surveyed by
REDCap. The interventions were delivered remotely.
So back when we did this, we mailed them a DVD, tailored DVD, and
then they got telephonic patient navigation.
And
the women didn't have to leave their homes to get the intervention.
And what we were trying to do was get the women up to date simultaneously with
breast, colon, cervical cancer. First time this type of intervention ever done.
We had a community advisory board-
Mm-hmm
... made of stakeholders that included women like the women we were
recruiting and agencies that served them for
these services. And they helped us from designing
every bit of the educational material, designing the
survey, designing all of the material that was patient-facing,
and then what do we do with the usual care?
They helped us figure out the newsletters we sent to them.
So you can do that across your five states.
You can do that.
That's what we're doing right now, though.
I'm trying to figure out how to involve them actually in the
research. So I... Right now-
To do the research? Or... There's human subjects issues, but they
can look at everything that's patient-facing.
Oh, yes. They're going to do that. But right now we're trying to get rural
representation-
Yeah
... because it's across Texas-
... Louisiana, Georg... Yeah, right.
Yeah.
So getting representation.
We do that all the time.
Outstanding. Constantine, looks like you have your hand up.
So we have a similar approach with not only with community
advisory boards, but community engagement studies that are study
specific. And if you do this as you're
designing it, not-
Mm
... halfway through the study when you see that you're not enrolling-
Right
... it made a difference.
Okay.
I like that. I think I'm just going to-
I'm going to get a double amen
... because I like that.
Yes. Yeah.
Okay, on that note, this has been fantastic.
Rick, thanks for being here and for your comments. Thank you all.
Wonderful panel here. I'm sure they'll talk to you if you come up quickly before
they go.